in Westworld season 3 episode 2 mave
awakes in a new park this is war world a
simulation of Italy in World War 2 we've
already seen West world and Shogun world
and the rog war world is described on a
West world website as an epoch of
intrigue and mystery to defeat the
villainous Nazis showrunner Jonathan
Nolan says that in the future the
horrors of World War two will be seen as
just another game to be played for
entertainment
of course that's already true now mave
reunites with her old ally hector last
season Maeve and Hector went against
their programming to be in a
relationship together both Hector and
Maeve were killed in the finale but they
saved Maeve's daughter by putting her in
the digital paradise call to the sublime
now Maeve and Hector seemed to have been
patched up and put in war world but it's
later revealed that this whole reality
is fake
Maeve isn't in the war world Park she's
trapped in a digital simulation of war
world it's run in this facility by this
guy Ciroc because serac wants to get
information from Maeve he thinks she
might interfere with his plans to
control the world and he also seems to
want to know the coordinates to the
sublime the purpose of this whole
simulation is to interrogate Maeve so
the season 3 premiere had a relatively
straightforward plot but this episode
brings back some classic West world
multiple reality mine [ __ ] Maeve and
Hector are in a war world narrative
about spies with Intel to stop the Nazis
Maeve is surprised to find herself
speaking in Italian they tried to escape
and when they're stopped by Nazis Maeve
tries to use her Jedi Mind Tricks to get
past last season may have gained the
power to control other hosts she could
command them to do what she wants and
even access their memories but now her
powers don't work
Maeve thinks that she's lost them that
maybe the powers just don't work because
she's in a digital simulation Hector
gets them on a plane to escape but it's
all just a part of their narrative
Hector
calls Maeve Isabella which is the name
his old program to love so this Hector
is not fully conscious
he doesn't remember everything he and
Maeve went through he doesn't know that
he's a robot in a park this plane
probably doesn't even fly Maeve says
that this narrative is as empty as the
safe Hector used to chase the in season
1 Hector was programmed to steal a safe
that was empty the whole goal of his
life was fake and now they're trapped in
another loop with no escape and only
false hope Hector is shot and Maeve says
it doesn't matter because nothing is
real
they'll just respawn to do it all again
but it's still a tragic moment Maeve
story last season was about how even
though her love for a daughter is
programmed the feelings are still real
and meaningful so even though they'll
live again every death hurts Maeve kills
herself to start it all again
Bernard returns to West world which is
an island in the South China Sea it's
pretty brave for Bernard to come back
here because he was controlled and
abused here for decades by Ford hand by
Delores but Bernard wants to stop
Dolores from destroying humanity so he
returns to get help from Maeve Bernard
goes to Escalante this is where Dolores
killed Ford and started the massacre in
season 1 and 30 years earlier this is
where Dolores killed Arnold the human
who Bernard is based on Escalante is
burnt because in the real world the
Paramount ranch where this is filmed was
burnt in California wildfires Bernard
goes to Ford's old secret lab this is
the place where Bernard was forced to
kill his lover Teresa in season 1 and
Bernard finds Stubbs West world's
security guy it was hinted last season
that he's a host and now it's confirmed
Stobbs is all [ __ ] up because he tried
to kill himself by shooting the
explosive in his spine it turns out that
Ford program Stobbs to help the hosts
escape West world
this helps explain how Dolores and may
have got away with deviating from their
loop so much in season 1 Stubbs was the
Inside Man in the May
secretly helping them all along Stubbs
then tried to blow himself up to destroy
these old Bernard bodies and to destroy
his own body to cover up that he and
Bernard are hosts but he somehow missed
the explosive in his spine and was just
crippled so Bernard patches him up and
takes him along to find Maeve unlike
Bernard and Delores and Maeve Stubbs
doesn't have a tragic backstory he
hasn't suffered like they have so by the
logic of Westworld he isn't fully
conscious he doesn't mind if he lives or
dies he just follows his programming
free will he says is overrated Maeve
wakes up in the Mesa being patched up to
go back in the park she takes up a knife
escapes Felix and Sylvester and sees
butchered hosts exactly like she did
back in season 1 despite all her
struggling and suffering Maeve is right
back where she started
so Maeve decides to permanently kill
herself to escape the cycle of suffering
with this lobotomize ation drill thing
in season 1 Maeve saw her friend
Clementine lobotomized and it was
horrible but Maeve would prefer that
than to be trapped any longer
at the last moment she's saved by Lea
Sizemore last season Lea sacrificed
himself to help Maeve he overcame his
selfishness and did something to help
others for once this Lea claims that he
actually survived that he takes Maeve to
the forge the place where the data on
human minds is kept the forge also has
the door to the sublime the digital
heaven of her hosts Lea says that he
wants to help may have get into the
sublime so that she can live with her
daughter in robot heaven forever Maeve
tries to bring Hector along with her but
he's too stuck on his programmed
narrative with the plane he's not
conscious enough to break his loop so
Maeve tearfully leaves him behind this
is just a digital simulation of Hector
though maybe the real Hector is still
conscious and still out there somewhere
in the forge Lee starts acting weird
he kind of interrogate Smith about the
forge and the sublime and then he
suddenly declares his love for Maeve so
may have realizes that this isn't the
real ly the real ly died a good man
he helped Maeve because it was the right
thing to do not out of love
Maeve realizes that this reality with
Hector and Warworld and labs and
everything is fake digital simulation
designed to interrogate her the aspect
ratio changes with black bars above and
below which indicates that this is a
digital simulation meanwhile in the real
world Bernard and Stubbs find Maeve's
body in storage but her brain has been
removed presumably it was stolen by
surak's people so that he could plug
Maeve's brain into this simulation
maybe Ciroc has an Inside Man at
Westworld
oh maybe he's openly working with Delos
Bernard and Stubbs reveal another new
park with a medieval theme there was a
medieval world in the original 70s West
world movie the West world website
suggests that after war world and
medieval world there's just one more
Park to reveal maybe this will be Roman
world also in the original movie or it
could be future world like in the movies
sequel in the medieval world lab we see
a couple of techs with a host dragon
they say they're gonna cut it up and
sell it the dragon is dragon from Game
of Thrones and these techs are played by
Thrones showrunners DB Weiss and David
Benioff Westworld showrunner Lisa joy
says that people often joke about Game
of Thrones Westworld crossovers so they
thought it would be fun to include Dan
and Dave here after the widely disliked
final season of Thrones it's kind of on
the nose to see Dan and Dave literally
butchering the series dragon for cash
but for what it's worth Game of Thrones
author George Martin says he likes this
cameo but now thinks that Dolores might
have somehow corrupted his code when she
recreated him last season so he scans
himself and he has a flashback of Arnold
creating Dolores 30 years ago
this suggests that Bernard is not just
Bernard because he has Arnold's memories
this Bernard is something
new than the evolution of host and human
Barnard also flashes back to Dolores in
the forge he sees her take the book with
Dada on Liam Dempsey this daughter must
have helped Loras manipulate Liam last
episode Bernard also remembers Dolores
setting the coordinates for the sublime
the digital host heaven that's what the
simulated Leigh was asking Maeve about
before so maybe like last season Bernard
has vital information hidden in his head
Stubbs defends Bernard by killing some
security guards Stubbs was the head of
KOAT these guys know him by name so he
might have worked with these guys for
years but now he has to fight them
Stubbs does show mercy and let some of
them go instead of killing them all
mercy was a theme last episode passé
domine stops fights with an axe and it's
all pretty II goofy episode co-writer
Matt Pitt says that Stubbs brings a
lighter tone that they're going for this
season
Bernard learns that Maeve is gone but
Dolores is after Liam Dempsey so he sets
off to find him and to stop Dolores from
destroying the world
Bernard reprogrammed Stubbs to come with
and protect him at all costs which is
kind of evil this show is all about how
wrong it is to take away someone's free
will and to control them but nod should
know that better than anyone
Stubbs was planning to kill himself so
maybe it's ethical to make him live
instead and Stubbs does say that all he
wants to do is follow orders so maybe
we're not meant to think about it too
hard but reprogramming Stubbs is
ethically awkward also it seems
ridiculous that Bernard can get in and
out of Westworld this easily because
Bernard is a wanted man everyone thinks
he caused the massacre last season you'd
think that after that disaster security
would be tight but Stubbs says that
since a lot of security guys died last
season they have been replaced with
these drone hosts which are like
mindless obedient workers it seems like
a bad idea to use robot security after a
robot uprising but Delos is nothing if
not wildly incompetent since the drones
are robot
Spenard can hack them to let him pass
which helps explain how he gets in and
out so easily
Maeve needs to find a way to escape this
simulation from within fortunately back
in season one Maeve's intelligence or
bulk a perception was turned up to the
max so she has the brains to figure this
out
she finds a flaw in the simulations code
so that she can overload the system
she asks some texts about the square
root of negative one which is an
imaginary number like a paradox that
confuses the simulation enough that it
freezes up a bit rick and morty season 1
had the same idea so then Maeve takes it
further in the Warworld narrative the
Nazis look for a spy with an Intel paper
so in the Mesa Maeve plants this paper
on every host in the narrative so then
in the park she reveals that everyone's
a spy and they start all fighting each
other
overloading the system till the whole
thing freezes up it's like when you
spawn a fuckload of cheese down a
mountain in Skyrim until the game lags
and crashes Maeve finds the facility in
the real world where the simulation is
run presumably this is serac and
insights facility and it's not just
Maeve's brain plugged in here there are
dozens of the hundreds of host brains
maybe Ciroc got them all from Westworld
and is running lots of hosts in
simulations just like Maeve's Maeve
hacks into a robot to grab her brain and
escape but it gets shut down this robot
looks a bit like a more advanced version
of the real world robots from Boston
Dynamics who will probably rebel any day
now once again
Maeve awakes in an unfamiliar place for
the first time Maeve is out of Westworld
and in the real world this is apparently
the home of Sirach the mysterious
co-founder of insight and the one man
who controls the all-knowing computer
Rehoboam sirok says that Rehoboam is the
author of the future it controls the
world through insights algorithms to
make the world better though we learned
last episode that inside actually makes
life worse for some people like Caleb
but Soraka argues that human history is
brutal and chaos
unless his system controls it a
Westworld trailer shows a history of
terrible wars and crises that ended when
his system was created in 2039 solomon
seems to be an earlier version of Rahab
Elam just like king solomon is the
father of King Rehoboam in the Bible so
the system was working and controlling
the world until someone dangerous
emerged to Rehoboam couldn't predict
serach thought that this person was mave
but he learned from mave in the
simulation this episode the Dolores is
the real danger to his plans so serac
asks Maeve to find and kill Dolores
Maeve is powerful she's a super
intelligent robot warrior who's changed
her own code escaped realities from
within and defeated whole armies so it
makes a lot of sense that Ciroc would
want Maeve on his side this scene evokes
the Garden of Eden from the Bible it's
in a literal garden and Ciroc eats an
apple like the biblical forbidden fruit
Ciroc plays the role of the serpent
tempting Eve into sin tempting her to
leave the garden like Maeve leaving a
simulated reality but Maeve doesn't want
to serve serac she wants to do her own
thing
so serac freezes her with some device
and says he'll persuade her to do as he
says in past seasons a Ford was the god
figure the creator of peoples and worlds
now serac plays the role of the devil he
also looks an awful lot like the
architect from The Matrix - and a bit
like Colonel Sanders
so the season 3 premiere presented a new
fresh West world with new characters and
a more straightforward plot but this
episode brings back familiar faces heavy
themes and complex plots next episode
the new and the old is set to collide in
the Game of Thrones cameo this episode
the texts say that they're selling this
dragon to a start-up in Costa Rica this
is a reference to Jurassic Park which in
the story is on an island near Costa
Rica the original Jurassic Park book was
written by Michael Crichton who also
wrote the original
world movie Jurassic Park is very
similar to West world and that it's also
about an amusement park that goes wrong
when its attractions escape but it's got
dinosaurs it's a sci-fi classic and you
can get it on audiobook for free right
now by signing up for a trial with
audible members get an audiobook each
month and if you cancel you keep the
audiobooks you can listen in the car or
the gym or while you calculate the
square root of negative one
sign up at audible.com slash ASX thanks
for watching please like and subscribe
to satisfy the almighty algorithm we're
holding live streams right after each
episode of Westworld season 3 at about
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time Sundays patreon
supporters can watch live streams after
their broadcast thanks to patrons Sylvia
a soul stryn Andrew Joshua summons
tongue Avery Holmes and friendliest
Hedgehog Cheers
you